i wanted to show them something that  wasn't an illusion  something that was real  something they could see  and touch  creation  is an act of sheer will  life  will find a way  we can't keep her here forever  they find her we're never going to see  her again we gotta protect her that's  our job  humans and dinosaurs can't coexist  [Music]  we created an ecological disaster  ali settler  alan grant  you didn't come out all this way just to  catch up now did you  you coming or what  [Music]  we're racing toward the extinction of  our species  [Music]  come back i always come back  that's another plane right  not exactly  [Music]  don't move  bigger why do they always have to go  bigger  [Music]